in schottland auf dem tückischen river
clyde ein tick nach steuerbord einen tag
nach steuerbord ein schlepper und ein
großes frachtschiff geraten in dichten
nebel
und wir was ist los was soll das jetzt
mit tödlichem ausgang
die ermittler untersuchen das frank rost
ja viele antworten auf unsere fragen
lagen auf dem grund sie rekonstruieren
die fatalen ereigniskette die drei
männer das leben kostete wir sind auf
grund gelaufen und die branche
grundlegend veränderte wir wollten
sicherstellen dass so etwas nie wieder
geschieht
[Musik]
der river clyde ist eine viel befahrene
wasserstraße die sich weit nach
schottland hinein schlängelt
die biosphären queren sportboote sind
unterwegs du siehst kleine tanker und
küsten schiffe da ist viel los auf dem
kleid man muss echt aufpassen
die schlepper sind die arbeitstiere hier
ihre crews geleiten die jährlich
hunderte von schiffen den schmalen
wasserlauf hinauf und hinab
die seeschiffe werden immer größer und
schwerer zu manövrieren ohne
schlepper geht das nicht in so engen
fahrerinnen
dabei ist es natürlich gefährlich so nah
an den riesen patton zu arbeiten
am 19 dezember 2007 machen sich die
schlepper auf dem kleid bereit für eine
schwierige mission
der 225 meter koloss red jasmin ist in
den fluss eingefahren es ist das größte
schiff auf dem kleid seit 20 jahren
sie war einfach riesig vom ufer aus
hatte man den eindruck ein hochhaus
würde vorbeifahren sie war ein wirklich
großes schiff
hat eine ladung tierfutter an bord
gelöscht werden soll sie in glasgow 27
kilometer flussaufwärts
kurz nach 17 uhr macht der lokale
schlepper bislang fand das fliegende
phantom die schleppt ross an dem
gigantischen frachter fest
die fem team setzt sich vor die jazzmen
um sie den windows reichen fluss entlang
zu gleiten
das schiff bevor ihr drei gesellt sich
zu retten am heck der jazzman hängen
soll sie den bremser spielen
als dritter schlepper soll schließlich
die malek ein auge auf alles haben um
einzugreifen falls es probleme gibt
nachdem der freien fenton signalisiert
wurde dass die leinen fast sein nahm der
schlepper fahrt auf ganz langsam und
vorsichtig
steve humphries der kapitän der phantom
ist ein erfahrener flussufer
ich kannte sie wie gut er war immer oben
am dock immer bei seinen schiffen
erkannte den fluss wie seine
westentasche
seit über zehn jahren auf dem fluss
unterwegs ist der erste offizier der 37
jährige brian
der decke der flying phantom ist eric
bradley
bob kamera misst ihr bord ingenieur
er war sehr praktisch veranlagt hat
immer irgend etwas repariert
kriegt alles wieder hin sagten die
männer auf dem schlepper
genau so muss ein bord ingenieur sein
damit alles glatt läuft geht ein lokale
lots an bord der jets mit
peter brennen wird engen kontakt zu den
schleppern halten
ein kleid bin ich bestimmt 1000 mal rauf
und runtergefahren rauf und runter rauf
und runter ich wohne nur ein paar
kilometer entfernt vom fluss
auf dem kleid darf man sich keinen
fehler erlauben
da gibt es ein stück von knapp 20 meilen
auf denen ein schiff nicht wenden kann
das macht druck du darfst keinen fehler
machen sonst stellt sich ein riesiges
teures schiff quer und blockiert den
ganzen fluss
ein weiterer faktor sind die gezeiten
ebbe und flut entscheiden wann große
schiffe fahren können
kleinere schiffe können rund um die uhr
auf dem kleid unterwegs sein was mit den
großen ist hängt von den gezeiten hat
wenn ein großes schiff flussaufwärts
fährt tickt die uhr
es gibt ein begrenztes zeitfenster sie
müssen den hafen erreichen bevor die
flut zurückgeht
bei einbruch der dunkelheit auf halber
strecke nach glasgow stehen die rap jazz
min und die schleppe vor einer ersten
herausforderung die enge kurve westlich
von damm backen
fenton bitte richtung steuerbord ziehen
mit der fremden sorgten dafür dass der
koloss die kurven exakt richtigen winkel
nimmt
damit wir brauchten den vorderen
schlepper um den 224 meter entfernten
bug zu bewegen und eine kleine kurve zu
fahren aber musste er gar nicht viel
ziehen
der bug der jasmin war so hoch dass ich
gerade mal den meister fand im sehen
konnte nur wenn sich der bub nach
backbord oder steuerbord bewegte war von
der brücke des schiffes aus erkennbar wo
sie sich befand
bis zu diesem punkt war es eigentlich
ein ganz normales manöver
das nur eine leichte kurve
die probleme begannen als sie in den
nebelgebieten
kontrolle dichter nebel bei der rente
fähre
zufällig hörte ich dass eine fähre
weiter oben auf dem fluss dichten nebel
meldete
im wetterbericht der hafenbehörde hieß
es sichtverhältnisse gut die kühle
schlepper und ich wurden vom nebel total
überrascht
noch länger woher kam der plötzlich
von nebel war nie die rede
für den kapitän eines schleppers ist die
räumliche orientierung enorm wichtig
er muss wissen wo sich die ufer und das
von ihm gezogene schiff befinden
das wetter schlägt um brennen aktiviert
die männer den dritten schlepper
ich schickte die manic aus die lager für
uns zu erkunden ford vor und checkt die
sichtverhältnisse für uns
vom oberlauf bestätigt die malick bat
die schlechte nachricht
hier herrscht dichter nebel
ich bin gleich zurück er sagte die
sichtweite wäre 15 20 meter wirklich
dichter nebel
wenige augenblicke später schlug der
nebel auch die radkästen
wir sahen kein ufer und kein wasser mehr
uns fehlte jeder visuelle anhaltspunkt
praktisch blind muss sich die rogers min
jetzt dorf ihr radar verlassen
man konnte die schlepper damit
eigentlich gut sehen auch die ufer wir
konnten unsere position im kanal halten
doch der gefährlichste abschnitt der
fahrt liegt noch vor ihnen
da ist eine hässliche beton rampe mit
einer extrem scharfen kante ein schiff
dass ihr zu nahe kommt wird quasi
seitlich aufgeschlitzt
brennen braucht die schlepper um den
gefährlichen hindernis auszuweichen
doch in dem dichten nebel kommt auch die
flying fenton nur zentimeterweise voran
zieht unseren tick nach steuerbord
wolltest einen tag nach steuerbord
mitten im nebel beginnt die fans die
rogers mit von der betonkante ford zu
ziehen
doch plötzlich wird aus einem bisschen
ziehen viel mehr
als erschöpft in kurven macht der
schiffs kompass ein ticken das geräusch
ein halbes grad und es macht klick klick
klick plötzlich klang ist wie
maschinengewehrfeuer was war los
jasmin kommt vom kurs ab wenn nicht
schnell etwas passiert kommt es zur
katastrophe für das schiff und für den
schlepper der im nebel vor ihm fährt
mit einer wenn wir sahen nichts keine
orientierung nirgends kein ufer keine
lichter
peter brenner der lotse an bord der
rezession befürchtet dass ein schiff in
richtung ufer gezogen wird
sie zu starker steuerbord doch die crew
auf dem schlepper hat eigenen probleme
hat
was war das
ich schaute auf das radar die flying
fenton schien am südufer auf grund
gelaufen zu sein
der schlepper steckt am hofer fest die
crew muss schnell handeln wie lange die
die rente mit der redmond verbindet muss
sofort gekappt werden
ein schlepper auf grund läuft kann ein
mit ihm vertrautes schiff zum kentern
bringen
die rente matthias man nicht länger an
der leine brennen muss handeln
maschinen aus voll zurück und forderte
den kapitän jasmin auf die maschinen zu
stoppen dann befahren nicht voll zurück
doch der massive schiffsrumpf steuert
weiter auf das ufer zu
77.000 tonnen schwere gigant lässt sich
nicht schnell zum halten bringen es
braucht wahrscheinlich eine meile bis so
ein koloss tatsächlich stopp
doch der not sein bordell jasmin hat
noch eine chance die katastrophe zu
verhindern ein weiterer schlepper hängt
am heck
die moria sollte kräftig am heck ziehen
um das schiff abzubremsen
es dauert fast eine minute bis so ein
riese zum stehen kommt doch für peter
brennen ist das drama noch lange nicht
vorbei
da stand ich nun mit diesem schiff einem
der größten auf dem kleid mitten auf dem
fluss im dichten nebel
bitte melden
bitte melden funkte
die flying fände man keine antwort
ich dachte okay die sind auf grund
gelaufen und haben jetzt andere sorgen
[Musik]
ich sah sie nicht erst herrschte dichter
nebel
brennen kann sich jetzt nicht um die
verkümmern
wenn ein großes schiff wie die red jazz
men abdriftet blockiert sie irgendwann
die ganze fahrrinne ich musste sie in
den hafen bringen irgendwann würde die
flut zurück gehen wohl ein gestrandetes
schiff das die fahrrinne blockiert
schlimmer kann es nicht kommen
damit wäre der hafen dicht
weiter vorne ist die magic im nebel
verschwunden brennan beschließt den am
heck der jazzman vertäuten schlepper
einzusetzen
die vario das schiff sec leicht drehen
um es für weitere manöver in die
richtige position zu bringen
[Musik]
langsame fahrt voraus bitte
hektisch gesteuert kriegt der koloss
durch den nebel
stets ganz langsam bewegten wir uns eine
meile vorwärts der nebel so dicht dass
wir die hand vor augen nicht sein
nach nervenaufreibenden 30 minuten
erreicht die rem in glasgow doch die
gefahr ist noch nicht gebannt sich blind
durch den nebel tastend fürchtet rennen
mit dem hafenkai zu kollidieren das will
er unbedingt vermeiden
wir hatten es fast bis zum anleger
geschafft doch ich sah nichts völlige
dunkelheit alles im nebel verschwunden
die bootsleute mit ihren
autoscheinwerfern zu markieren wo bug
und heck positioniert werden sollten
im scheinwerferlicht der autos
manövriert die crew die rogers man sich
an die mole
längsseits die leinen wurden ausgeworfen
die festmacher fing sie auf
die schwierige fahrt nach glasgow ist
beendet
ich war erleichtert ich dachte gott sei
dank wir haben es geschafft
es war ein albtraum das schiff mit einem
schlepper flussaufwärts zu schleusen
doch brennan hat kaum zeit durchzuatmen
gleich wird er erfahren dass vier männer
im eiskalten fluss hinter hin um ihr
leben kämpfen
mitte dezember
dichter nebel liegt über dem
schottischen river clyde
der schlepper antwortet nicht die
binnenschiffer näher kindes hört dass
die freien fenton auf grund gelaufen ist
wie es auf der sandbank vielleicht
können wir was tun kassel und er fahren
raus um hilfe zu bitten
aber ich ging auf und sprach mit kies er
sagte dass sein bester freund stevie mit
der flying kärnten vor dem dock auf eine
sandbank gelaufen sei wir scherzen noch
lachten über stevie weil er den
schlepper auf grund gesetzt hatte
auf dem wasser wird mehr kinder schnell
klar wie tückisch die lage ist
wir fuhren mit nur einem knoten die
sichtverhältnisse waren katastrophal vom
bug des schiffes wo ich stand konnte ich
kita am steuer nicht erkennen so ein
nebel hatte ich noch nie erlebt
hat sie sich nähern entdeckt mehr kindes
plötzlich
der markt der fly and umklammert sich
völlig durchnässt an den mast einer boni
begrenzen ihn an bord
so ist gut geschafft
er war völlig unterkühlt total
durchgefroren ich gab ihm eine jacke ich
weiß nicht wie er es geschafft hat den
mast nicht loszulassen
immer wieder sagte er alle weg wer ist
weg und
der schlepper
langsam begriffen wir das hier war ein
großes problem
ganz in der nähe finden sie was von der
flying fenton übrig ist
da war ein bisschen platz ein halber
meter oder so zwischen nebel und wasser
ich lehnte mich über den brand und
entdeckte aufsteigenden blasen
hier muss es sein sagt dich zu tief mehr
markiert die stelle
der schlepper ist im eiskalten wasser
des kleid gesunken von der restlichen
crew fehlt jede spur
[Musik]
derweil ist oben in glasgow die rangers
man nun fest vertäut
sexting als nächstes funken wir die
suite zamalek an den dritten schlepper
unsere escort
dass man was ist mit dem
wir glauben sie ist verloren
ich dachte zuerst er meint verloren im
nebel dass er nicht wüsste wo er ist die
tasse novelli es dass er weiß nicht wo
er ist
glauben sie
das war ein schock als wir zuletzt
sprachen war sie auf grund gelaufen und
jetzt heißt es der schlepper sei
gekentert und gesunken
es war ein totaler schock für mich
rasch macht sich die küstenwache auf die
suche nach den vermissten männern unter
ihnen ist auch bob cameron der
bordingenieur
um 20 uhr klingelte mein telefon
ich war nicht schnell genug der abbé
sprang an da hörte ich die nachricht
[Musik]
du kommst zu mir ins zimmer und sagte
das hätte einen unfall gegeben mein
vater sagte stone wir wussten aber noch
nicht was geschehen war
[Musik]
18 stunden dauert die verzweifelte suche
nach der vermissten crew bereits an über
60 leute helfen an land und auf einem
dutzend schiffe die auf dem fluss
kreuzen
aber es wird bald klar dass es keine
weiteren überlebenden gibt
das war völlig unvorstellbar dass ein
schlepper sinkt und drei menschen
sterben pauli waren ein absoluter schock
starre
in den folgenden tagen werden die
leichen der männer geborgen
kapitäns die wie humphrey bord ingenieur
bob kamera und martha ripley konnten
sich nicht mehr aus dem schiff befreien
wie findet viele kamen zur beerdigung
die kirche war da waren über 1000 leute
alle bänke waren besetzt
doch einer kann linda und lorna keinen
trost spenden peter brammen
wer sie fragten mich ob ich mit den
witwen sprechen wollte ich konnte es
nicht ich konnte ihn nicht ins gesicht
sind nicht weil ich mich schuldig fühlte
ich war einfach zu geschockt und traurig
[Musik]
menschen waren gestorben
die branche sucht nach ursachen
die britische sie unfall
untersuchungsbehörde schaltet sich ein
nicolas hens leitet die untersuchung
ich wusste nicht was mich erwarten würde
als ich den fall übernahm
ich kannte weder den fluss gleiten auch
die passage flussaufwärts ich hatte viel
zu lernen eine dreiköpfige schiffs
besatzung wurde vermisst es gab einen
überlebenden mehr war mir nicht bekannt
einer der ersten mit denen
danke dass sie sich die zeit für unser
gespräch
wir müssen versuchen so zeitnah wie
möglich mit den zeugen zu sprechen um
eine ungefähre aussage zu bekommen
ich möchte verstehen was passiert ist
der überlebende der phantom war
natürlich ein ganz wichtiger zeuge
wir sind auf grund gelaufen
ich hab die leine gelöst sie befohlen
aufgewühlt beschreibt agent sind die
dramatischen letzten momente der
fantasy zu starker steuerbord
wir sind auf grund gelaufen
alleine gelöst
die schützen erinnert sich dass die
flammen konnten wenige sekunden nachdem
sie fest saß gefährlich auf eine seite
kränkte
und was ist los
raus alle raus
ich bin auf der steuerbordseite raus
ich dachte die anderen folgen mir aber
er hat keine wahl er muss von bord
[Musik]
noch im bann der katastrophe kann es
nicht erklären warum das schiff sagt
ich finde selbst zu tür
[Musik]
ein weiterer wichtiger zeuge ist peter
brenner fans will auch mit ihm sprechen
die gleich am nächsten tag standen die
ermittler vor der tür
[Musik]
ich war immer noch geschockt ich spürte
symptome einer posttraumatischen
belastungsstörung
der zweifel bleibt ja habe ich etwas
getan dass sie in gefahr gebracht hat
in den medien heißt es bremen sei schuld
an der tragödie
sie behaupteten die red jazzmen habe die
feier fand im garten das ganze war enorm
aufgeladen
waren die beiden schiffe im dichten
nebel kollidiert
im vergleich zu einem ozeanriesen ist
ein schlepper winzig ein manövrierfähig
kann durchaus zu einer kollision führen
die den schlepper zum kind an bringt
im nebel und in der dunkelheit hatte
peter brennen es nicht sehen können wenn
der schlepper unter jazmin geraten wäre
[Musik]
der mission form bringt einen derartigen
nebel hatte ich noch nie erlebt ich
funkte sie nochmal an wollte checken ob
alles okay ist
er antwortete nicht
ich nehme an sie hätten genug damit zu
tun das schiff wieder frei zu bekommen
[Musik]
sie haben zwar zwei augenzeugen doch die
ermittler wissen noch immer nicht warum
die feier fand im st
[Musik]
fans und sein team setzen auf innovative
technik
damals im jahr 2007 waren es
automatische systeme zur
positionsbestimmung eine recht neue
sache
ermittlern bieten sie jede menge
informationen über position
geschwindigkeit und kurs von schiffen
wir spielten alle daten zur position der
feier fand im und der rogers min und
unser meta system ein um zu
rekonstruieren welches schiff sich wann
wo befand
damit konnten wir die genaue position
der flying fand im verhältnis zur etwas
mitbestimmen auf ungefähr zehn meter
genau
die irs angaben belegen zweifelsfrei
dass die reds mit den schlepper nicht
gerammt hat der abstand zwischen den
schiffen war ausreichend als das unglück
geschah
was ist passiert
es muss eine andere ursache dafür geben
dass der schlepper kenterte und sank
hens muss sich das werk genauer ansehen
die antworten auf unsere fragen lagen
auf dem grund des flusses und zwar klar
ohne den gesunkenen schlepper zu
untersuchen kämpfe nicht weiter das
wrack liegt nicht sehr tief doch hans
merkt schnell dass sich die erhofften
antworten nicht so leicht finden lassen
januar 2008 ein schlepper senkt drei
männer sterben noch liegt das fragt im
schottischen river clyde die ermittler
setzten einen taucher ein
gleich nach neujahr rief mein chef an du
musst so schnell wie möglich zur freien
fans liegen
der erfahrene bergungstaucher
terre'blanche macht sich von südafrika
auf den weg nach schottland
ich wollte wissen in welcher position
sich ruder und strahlrohr düsen befanden
ich wollte wissen was in diesen letzten
momenten geschah
tatsächlich war ich viel zu optimistisch
beim ersten versuch zieht es
terre'blanche sofort flussabwärts
[Musik]
die strömung war heftig mindestens vier
knoten beim ersten eintauchen riss es
mich gleich am schlepper vorbei ich
trieb auf dem wasser und zog an der
leine damit die jungs mich rausholen
terre'blanche begreift schnell dass die
starke thiede des flusses bestimmt wann
er tauchen kann und wie lange
ein gezeitenwechsel flaut die strömung
ab knapp eine stunde sinkt sie auf
ungefähr einen anderthalb knoten dann
kannst du tauchen
doch diese zeiten sind nicht das einzige
problem für das thema
bild ist da gut
das wasser ist so trübe das tableau
schon mit ihm die ermittler kaum etwas
erkennen
sehr sicht gleich null
es ist ein völlig verschlammt fluss
alles braun total braun terre'blanche
muss das gesunkene schiff quasi blinkt
der kunden
du springst ins wasser und dann passt
das du dich vor deine hände sind deine
augen ja das habe ich auf dem plan
gesehen fühlt sich an wie ein
luftschacht oder ein türgriff auf dem
zweiten weg
es dauerte eine weile bis ich mich
orientieren konnte
war ich am bug mit schiffs am heck nicht
einfach die mission
für die ermittler ist vor allem
interessant fast terre'blanche am boden
der fan thema kennen kann wurde der
rumpf aufgerissen hat sich das schiff
dem hofer näherte
der schlepper manövrieren auf engem raum
und manchmal laufen sie auf grund
das wird dann problematisch wenn da
unten felsen oder andere hindernisse
sind die können großen schaden
verursachen
der kleid wirkt auch noch andere
gefahren riesige rampen über die schiffe
zu wasser gelassen werden säumen das
ufer
diese rampen sind aus massivem beton
mit einem pfahl am ende dem schiff wie
ein dosenöffner den boden auf schneiden
kann
[Musik]
tauchen im bug der phantom ist harte
arbeit
nach mehreren tagen sorgfältiger
untersuchung entdeckt er bloß etwas das
erklären könnte warum die fan team so
schnell sank allerdings nicht am
schiffsrumpf
das kann nicht sein
so sicher alle türen sind so
tastete weiter und bestätigte dann ja es
ist eine tür er sagte ich solle sie
schließen das ging nicht ich fühlte dass
sie festgebunden war wurde ihm sofort
drauf
komm raus
wir müssen stoppen sagten sie sofort
halt den taucher auf wir müssen reden
sie stellten fest dass eine der
wasserdichten türen auf dem hauptdeck
offenstand und festgebunden war
das ist ungewöhnlich
das hauptdeck eines schleppers befindet
sich nur knapp über der wasseroberfläche
wenn wasser ins schiff dringt vor allem
in den maschinenraum der stabilisiert
dass seine lage und kann es zum kentern
bringen
tabs als reiter
wenn das schiff in seitenlage gerät und
die tür offen ist fließt das wasser
direkt in den maschinenraum flutet ihn
und der schlepper sinkt schneller
ich tauchte auf und wir diskutierten die
lage
letztlich stellten sich andere fragen
warum ist sie gesunken sagt sie weil die
tür offen stand was war geschehen die
ermittler wollen mögliche wichtige
beweise nicht beschädigen sie
beschließen das wrack so schnell wie
möglich zu heben
sie wollten die fans um hoch holen und
zwar schnell
32 tage nach ihrem untergang wird die
flying fenton gehoben den ermittlern
bietet sich ein überraschendes bild
sie hatten erwartet dass das schiff
völlig zerstört wäre doch das war nicht
der fall es gab keine löcher durch die
wasser eingedrungen wäre endlich können
die ermittler das ganze schiff
untersuchen sie bestätigen dass die
freien fenton nicht von der ages mit
gerahmt oder durch steine oder metall
aufgerissen wurde
möglicherweise spielte die geöffnete tür
beim kentern eine rolle doch es ist
immer noch nicht klar warum der
schlepper so stark in seitenlage geriet
das wasser das schiff fluten konnte es
muss einen anderen auslöser für die
tragödie gegeben doch welchen
vor über einem monat lang die flinte und
drei männer starben
letzter der schlepper gehoben ist können
sich die ermittler auch im inneren
umsehen
[Musik]
wir organisierten eine provisorische
beleuchtung und lüfter damit die leute
an bord gehen und die untersuchung
fortsetzen konnten
wir sollten anzeigen machten fotos
schauten was die instrumente und sagten
und überlegten was aus den positionen
der verschiedenen regler zu schließen
wäre
es ist ein gespenstisches bild von den
letzten augenblicken des schleppers
mit den aufnahmen der funksprüche
rekonstruiert der leitende ermittler
nicolas fans die tragischen ereignisse
der nacht
wir sind auf grund gelaufen
alleine gelöst
der einzige überlebende der havarie sagt
er habe die leine gelöst doch die
ermittler fragen sich ob sein gedächtnis
ihm einen streich spielt
die schlepper müssen aufpassen dass die
zuglast nicht seitlich über das schiff
gezogen wird und es damit umreißt
das nennt man götting wenn die zu kleine
nicht mehr hinter sondern über dem
schlepper liegt kann es binnen sekunden
zur katastrophe kommen
[Musik]
körting ist ein risiko für schlepper man
muss aufpassen dass der schletter nicht
vom schiff gezogen wird das gilt es
unbedingt zu vermeiden sonst droht der
schlepper zu kentern
war das das schicksal der fans
die ermittler untersuchen den
schaltknopf mit dem deal eine gelöst
wird denn eher gedrückt wurde müsste er
immer noch in dieser position sein
im steuerhaus gibt es normalerweise
einen knopf mit dem man einen
mechanismus betätigt der die sperre der
winde löst
dann dreht sich die trommel bis die
schleppt rosse komplett abgerollt ist
das schauen wir uns mal an zu diesem
zeitpunkt war uns bekannt dass der knopf
gedrückt worden war ob er funktioniert
hatte wussten wir nicht
es zeigte sich dass das brems band nicht
nötig wenn die notentriegelung war also
offenbar ausgelöst worden und hat er
funktioniert bei der untersuchung der
binde entdeckt enz einen wichtigen
beweis das schleppseil mit dem die
beiden schiffe verbunden werden
ich brauche ein foto hier von
zunächst hieß ist dass das schleppseil
durchgeschnitten wurde das war jedoch
nicht der fall tatsächlich war es
gerissen
kleinen sind speziell konstruiert
leicht und damit gut handhabbar für die
crew aber sehr stabil ihre bruch dehnung
beträgt knapp 200 tonnen
wie konnte so viel gewicht auf einer
leine lasten die der schlepper gelöst
hatte
nun konzentrieren wir uns verstärkt auf
die winde
wir zogen mehrere experten zu rate sie
pumpten das öl aus der hydraulik füllten
neues öleinfuhren das system wieder hoch
und führten diverse tests an der winde
aus um zu sehen wie sie funktionierte
die ermittler belasten die leine um die
spannung beim schleppen eines schiffs zu
simulieren ihr habt reinhard onnen drauf
okay lassen wir
doch als sie die notentriegelung
aktivieren was ist jetzt los dauert es
bis sich etwas tut
[Musik]
wiederholen wir den versuch
die notentriegelung wurde aktiviert auch
sie reagierte viel zu langsam alleine
lösen
es dauerte sechs bis acht sekunden bis
sich das brems band hoch
die kur auf dem schlepper dachte sie
wäre nicht mehr mit der rap jazz mit
verbunden doch mehrere kritische
sekunden lang bestand die verbindung
weiter
die leinen die direkt aufwärts ziehen
sollte zog die pflanzen unter wasser
ich bin im prinzip überholte die red
jazz men lief langsam und das brachte
diese zum kentern wenn mittag der bug
schlepper wurde nun von dem
riesenfrachter gezogen
beim untergehen belastete der sinkende
schlepper die leine weit über deren
limit
hatten plötzlich hing ein 500 tonnen
schwerer gesunkener schlepper an der
leine bis iris
menn bitte melden
bitte melden hoch oben auf der jazz men
und im nebel praktisch blind an peter
brand nicht welche tragödie sich unten
ab spielt
auf einem 77.000 tonnen schiff spürst du
nicht wenn unten ein schlepper hin und
hergezogen wird bis die leine reist
das kriegst du da oben gar nicht mit
[Musik]
die crew hat alles richtig gemacht doch
sie wird opfer eines fehlers in einem
wichtigen system
jetzt müssen die ermittler herausfinden
ob es sich um eine einmalige
fehlfunktion handelt oder ob ein
ähnliches risiko auch für andere kurs
besteht
wir sind auf grund gelaufen löst die
leine alleine gelöst
die ermittler stellen fest dass die
verzögerung der notentriegelung den
untergang des schleppers auf dem
schottischen river clyde verursacht hat
harry hat also der schlepper geriet in
schwierigkeiten und drückte die
notentriegelung diese funktionierte
nicht
haben wir uns die normen für schlepptau
winden und entwicklungsmechanismen vor
und fanden heraus dass es keine
vorschriften dafür gab wie schnell der
mechanismus wirken sollte
wegen der art der testverfahren
verwinden war die potenziell tödliche
verzögerung bis dahin unbemerkt
geblieben und
wir testen die notentriegelung der
winden mindestens einmal im monat
manche unternehmen testen sogar täglich
da es schwer ist die winden unter
belastung zu testen finden die tests
jedoch ohne last stadt und die winde
scheint zu funktionieren
die ganze branche war geschockt als sich
herausstellte dass es sechs bis acht
sekunden dauern kann bis der mechanismus
einsetzt
[Musik]
doch das bis dahin unbekannte probleme
der winde war nicht der einzige faktor
die tür zum maschinenraum statt offen
und variiert das ist der crew noch
weniger zeit zu reagieren
wäre die tür zum maschinenraum
geschlossen gewesen hätte kein wasser
eindringen und bis zum abzug schacht
steigen können die neigung hätte dann
knapp 40 grad betragen bei geschlossener
tür hätte die flying fenton eine größere
chance gehabt dass körting zu überleben
dazu kam der dichte nebel
man sah die hand vor augen nicht der
kleinste fehler konnte so dramatische
folgen haben
in jener nacht betrug die sichtweite
gerade mal ein paar meter die schiffe
sahen sich gegenseitig nicht mehr sie
waren praktisch split
die ermittler prüfen auch in dieser
hinsicht die sicherheitsvorschriften und
stellen fest dass es keine klaren
vorgaben für schlepp vorgänge bei
dichtem nebel gibt
klar hast du jede menge instrumente aber
es gab keine definierten grenzwerte oder
vorgeschriebenen maßnahmen oder
schulungen für die schlepper die unter
solchen bedingungen operierten die crew
musste in einer situation reagieren auf
die sie nicht vorbereitet und für die
sie nicht ausgerüstet war
viele jahre sind vergangen seit die drei
männer an bord der wein fand auf dem
river clyde starben
[Musik]
die branche aus dem unglück gelernt bei
dichtem nebel gelten neue regeln
der schlepp vorgang ist zu stoppen bis
sich die wetterbedingungen verbessern
[Musik]
die notentriegelung wird nun vor jeder
fahrt getestet sie muss auslösen sobald
der knopf gedrückt wird
mittlerweile gibt es weltweit
vorschriften für die notentriegelung
die unter allen umständen und so schnell
wie möglich reagieren muss
egal ob die winde unter spannung steht
ob unter hoher oder niedriger belastung
der gesetzlich zulässige zeitraum für
eine mechanische reaktion beträgt
maximal drei sekunden
wenn wir glück haben wird sich ein fall
wie der der freien fand nie wiederholen
seit 2007 hat sich die schlepperfahrt
neu aufgestellt doch peter brammen ist
nicht mehr dabei
ich konnte mich nicht mehr auf meine
arbeit als lotse konzentrieren am ende
gab ich auf das war nichts mehr für mich
seit jahren kämpfe ich mit den folgen
jener nacht ob ich sie je bewältigen
werde weiß ich nicht doch brennen ist
nicht der einzige der mit der erinnerung
an den tragischen unfall leben muss
da wo die flying fand am st hat derart
von clyde bank eine gedenktafel
angebracht
wir legen dort jedes jahr am 19 dezember
blumen
[Musik]
es war ein schrecklicher unfall
und zwar wichtig dass alles getan wurde
damit sich das nie wiederholt damit
niemand anderes durchmachen muss was wir
durchgemacht haben
[Musik]